[Music]
this week on
forward the current generation of
leaders have got to be replaced with
Next Generation leaders who understand
what's coming who have a different
worldview different competencies and
most of all are ready to work together
to solve problems stop fighting each
other and start fighting for each other
that's my agenda I I don't understand
how it is possible that the Democratic
party would literally suppress Millions
of democratic voters and I think it's
not just hypocritical it's just
downright dangerous downright foolish
and frankly
[Music]
inexcusable it is my pleasure to Welcome
to the podcast three- term member of
congress former CEO of talenti gelato
Democratic presidential candidate
Congressman Dean Phillips joining us
today welcome Dean hey Andrew great to
be with you my friend you are beaming in
from New Hampshire is that right how are
things going I'm literally beaming
because it is the most amazing joyful
inspirational
reinvigorating month of my life it's
going great you know there's a a massive
as you well know a massive disconnect
between Washington and the real world
and people here in the granite state are
amazing uh ready for change completely
disenchanted with what they're seeing on
both ballots right now and I'm excited
about January 23rd it's I think it's
going to be a real surprise yeah so you
and I have known each other uh for about
a year or so uh we met in DC when you
were a member and uh I liked you
immediately because we were at a
campaign Finance reform event and you
said hey DC is even worse than I thought
I'm the only member who doesn't dial for
dollars I thought I was kind of here to
legislate and do do something good and
uh and I heard this and I said wow uh
like more of America should hear about
this guy uh and and then you made
headlines where you said what you
actually thought which was hey uh maybe
candidates other than Joe Biden should
consider running um not because Joe
Biden is not a good person um but he may
not be the best candidate um to field
and then you got a tremendous amount of
back from that at least that was the
sense I I got from the outside looking
in that's a fair that's a fair that's a
good sense you got and I'd imagine that
that must have been sort of bewildering
for you because people were saying the
exact same thing as you were saying in
private they were thinking the same
thing and then you said something that
in my mind was fairly conventional
wisdom and all of a sudden it was like
this headline making oh like Dean is um
somehow sticking a a black eye on the
party or something
and was was that the um was that the
experience from your side well first of
all you know Andrew let me let me
compliment you you know when over the
last year as we've gotten to know each
other you know I had some perspective
from the inside of Congress and the
inside of Washington and you had had
this experience running for president
from the outside and I'm discovering uh
what you did last time around and I
shared with you what I discovered uh
from the inside you know both have
significant deficiencies that need to be
addressed and I'll tell you the disease
that is afflicting both is a disease of
Silence uh and a disease of fear uh and
a lack of courage and what you just said
is people say one thing privately and
they say something totally different
publicly which is why I think only 10%
of Americans have uh significant faith
in their Congress and it makes perfect
sense so that's the disease I used to
think it was only a disease of the right
uh when Donald Trump was President my
Republican colleagues would say the same
thing every day quietly he's a appalling
he's dangerous uh his character is is
horrifying and then they get in front of
the cameras and lights and say that he
was the greatest thing since sliced
bread and then I started hearing the
same stuff on my side people having
conversations about President Biden's
deficiencies uh the decline the numbers
the fear that he's going to lose uh and
now almost the certainty that he's going
to lose and yet when they get in front
of cameras and in public say something
totally different and I think that is
the most dangerous a front to democracy
when people in elected positions trying
to represent people ostensibly say
something different than they feel and
I'll tell you when 70 some percent of
the country wants neither Joe Biden nor
Donald Trump to be the next president
and only one member of Congress out of
535 really stood up and said it which is
me we got problems and I torpedoed my
career but my goodness I do it a
thousand times over because this is a
big deal it's existential yeah it was a
High character move on your part um man
it it's something that too few of our
political figures are willing to do um
you I had some advantages in that you
know I I wasn't elected official
anyway but in your case I mean you you
had reached what for many people is the
Pinnacle um you ran a race in a very
competitive even red leaning District
that hadn't been represented by a
Democrat um for decades uh before you
got there and then you w up surprising
everyone in winning um but in your last
race you won by double digits because
people like you you know like a
reasonable man you get things dud uh and
so you had that position sewn up if you
wanted it uh I mean we all know like you
have a 94% real like rate for incumbent
members as long as you were the good uh
party loyalist you could have just hung
out there
forever but but like most people do yeah
like most people do um but uh one thing
I really like about you is that you're
not someone for whom this is a a job
that's um frankly a better job than
other jobs you could have or other jobs
you've already had you know there
actually a service job but you went
through a process yourself where you
said look and I saw some of the
headlines it was entertaining to me
honestly um where where you went through
this process and said I may not be the
best situated to run for president I
think I would be a fine president which
by the way I agree with you knowing you
you're a High character a high int
person with real values and real
judgment and you would make uh a great
president but you were humble enough to
say look I might not be well situated to
run um so let me try and get someone
else to run um so what was that process
like well so Andrew it started first of
all thanks for your fine your nice
comments uh you're right I woke up the
morning after the 2016 election uh to
the sound of my youngest daughter who
was 16 at the time crying in her bedroom
and she had just overcome Hodgkins
lymphoma she's a a gay woman I did not
know that at the time and she was really
afraid about her future I think about
the country's future it left a really
indelible mark on me as her dad and I
sat at the breakfast table that morning
after the election and I promised both
of my daughters that I would do
something and as you said flipped a
district that had been Republican red
for 60 years uh beat a guy by who had
won by 14 points beat him by 12 and now
of course last time one by just under 20
and my mission was to resist and defend
the country from Donald Trump and I
thought after two terms or so I'd be
finished with that mission and the fact
of the matter is he's coming back so
last year uh July 30th to be exact I was
on a radio show in my hometown in
Minneapolis was asked by the host if I
thought the President should run again
and I said no because he had essentially
indicated explicitly if not implicitly
that he would not and I was really
shocked along with just about everybody
in Washington when he decided to do it
again for a lot of reasons and when that
happened I started calling calling on
others to do it because I think that is
an existential threat to the country and
democracy if Donald Trump wins again and
I made calls to Gretchen Whitmer to JB
pritzer I made public calls exactly as
you said to those who were better known
and had already developed National
fundraising and
organizational um capacities to actually
run for president and yes I think I'll
make a fine president and I look forward
to doing so but I was not prepared at
that time to run and setting up a
presidential campaign in two weeks
before one launches uh is not highly
recommended but the times beg for it and
in the absence of anybody doing it uh I
finally determined two weeks before I
announced on October 27th that someone
had to someone who had the potential to
actually beat Donald Trump and that's
why I'm considering this the most
principled journey of my entire life
because I really did believe and I know
how much name recognition matters but
I'll tell you Andrew I've come to
discover something really amazing which
is when you're not well known that means
half of the country does not hate you
yet and I think that makes for a fine
opportunity to actually build my brand
introduce myself develop name
recognition uh and get to May or June of
next year when the national polls I
believe are going to say that I will
beat Donald Trump and President Biden
will lose and if anyone is paying
attention you'll know that just
yesterday President Biden finally
acknowledged that there are probably 50
Democrats who could beat Donald Trump
not just him so I think there you've got
it and that's exactly what the mission
I'm on right now and it's going really
really well yeah from from my vantage
point Dean uh it is madness to run uh an
81-year-old unpopular incumbent with a
37% approval rating who is down in the
swing States represents the status quo
easily the oldest uh president in
history uh against someone like Donald
Trump who would be a catastrophe in
office his second term would make his
first term look like sanity Central in
my opinion his second term would be
cataclysmic and you know who I have a
bone to pick with and I don't know if
you feel this way but I'll say it um I I
have a real problem now with Gavin Nome
JB pritzker Gretchen Whitmer these other
folks who clearly are gearing up for a
run for the White House but are lying in
waight uh for 2028 I mean what the
hell's going to be left for us in 2028
if Trump wins in 2024 I feel like people
like that are putting their own
professional interests ahead of the
countries and it makes me think of them
as frankly unpresidential um and and
that's something that I
feel I mean for you to say that might be
a little bit harsh and rough but like I
I want to put that idea out there do you
have any response to that yeah that was
my message Andrew that you can't wait
till 2028 because we probably will not
have one at least an election that we've
come to know and that's exactly my point
you know you got to run to the fire when
your country is burning not away from it
and I'm disappointed I I think they're
good people that's why I called them I
think they should have and could have
joined the stage and offered their names
but I have to tell you the one my one
defense of them is I think they knew
better than I how this machine turns on
anybody you know what I mean I mean it
and I want to be forthright I think they
know I think why Gavin Nome is doing
everything but getting on the ballot
because he knows what happens if you
would so much as raise your voice and
have the audacity to enter your name on
a Democratic primary ballot when the
country needs you he knows what the
machine will do and they're doing it to
me and I was not prepared for it I did
not expect uh the weight uh the
antagonism uh and frankly the delusion
the delusion of a party that really
should be focusing on debate on
competition and participation and
instead of promoting those three things
they are literally working against it I
do think those candidates understand how
this works my only disappointment is
that they're not participating in fixing
it and the best way to fix it would be
to join the race not just one not just
two let's have three four five of us
doing what you do in democracy look at
the Republican ticket Donald Trump is
560 points ahead of everybody that was
on stage there last night right that's
not stopping them from doing it
not stopping them and he's not showing
up to debate either Biden's not showing
up to debate I think we have a real
crisis and I'm I'm disappointed I think
they should have and could have and if
they're waiting till 2028 like you said
I think that shows a deficiency when a
country really really needs someone uh
and that's exactly why I'm subjecting
myself to this and I've torpedoed my
career in Congress and that's okay
because I was not willing to see the
country torpedoed by Donald Trump indeed
man I mean when when I decided to run in
the last cycle I said to myself you know
what uh no matter what I'm going to be
able to look in at myself in the mirror
and say I did everything I could like
I'll be able to sleep at night you know
I mean like that's the most important
test and you should be sleeping soundly
because you're definitely putting it all
I'll sleep I'll sleep soundly I'll sleep
soundly the day after the election next
November hey YouTube thanks for watching
in please do hit like And subscribe and
hit that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you yeah exactly because January 23rd
again is this massive opportunity for
the voters to speak um because the
voters should like the voters see all
this stuff coming I mean if you talk to
the average person on the street and
just say Joe Biden's name like they'll
shake their head and say he's too old I
mean that that's what 70% of Americans
think now now the process you're going
through right now Dean is a process I've
been through um and you have to do it
faster than I did it's good fun um but
what what happens is at first you
identify a need um and you've identified
the correct need I mean we're about to
serve the country up to Trump again
honestly like almost on a silver platter
it's really embarrassing uh that like
the the Democratic party in my opinion
is failing us all by not having a proper
uh competition which you are doing your
best to force and uh you know I
appreciate the heck out of you for it um
but the the process you're going through
right now is helping others imagine you
as president what is that Vision uh let
let's say and by the way I think you
have a very very real chance of becoming
the next president of the United States
uh you know I think the majority of
Democrats don't want Joe um the the
Machinery is trying to protect Joe but
uh as soon as the voters have their say
I think there's a very real chance that
uh they do the country a massive
service and say like you know we need
someone else in there but it's January
2025 you get sworn in uh you're the new
president of United States um what is
top of the list in terms of the things
that you want to express or get done let
me start with the most important which
is how I will lead and I'm going to lead
very differently I'm going to have a
Team of Rivals in the White House Andrew
uh not unlike Abraham Lincoln put
together in the 1860s during the worst
crisis in American history to that point
the Civil War he recognized that every
American had to have their voice inside
the White House he needed to put people
at that table who had different
perspectives but had to lead the country
together and I think it's time for every
single future president of the United
States to ensure that he or she does not
just populate the White House staff and
cabinet with people who all see things
the the same way I think that's actually
destructive to democracy and it is
destroying the country that's one I'll
also have a youth cabinet it's time to
bring young people's voices into the
White House delegate from every one of
the 50 states all Races religions colors
backgrounds uh and politics and
geographies uh to come up with great
ideas about social media regulation
about uh the future of AI both the
blessings and the curses climate change
gun violence prevention the things that
young people are most focused on for
good reason and have great ideas about
I'm going to employ zerob based
budgeting I'm going to finally have
every single agency of the United States
federal government assessed by an
outside consulting firm to identify ways
to save money deliver Services better
more eff efficiently and effectively and
finally the Pentagon will pass an audit
these are absolutes as the next leader
I'd be the broad I'd have the most
experience Andrew strangely enough of
any recent president having built and Le
companies having served as the board
chair of a large Health System uh a
regent at a university
board chair of a charitable Foundation a
board member of a public company and now
three terms in the United States
Congress a member of House Democratic
Leadership ranking member of the Middle
East subcommittee on Foreign Affairs and
also the vice ranking member of the
small business committee I have very
broad experience and I will use that
management experience which very few
occupants of the White House have had to
lead better uh and most of all to
develop Common Ground if we do not
repair the country use common sense and
decency and restore
faith and government nothing I talk
about right now is going to matter so
what's next affordability affordability
and affordability there is a massive
disconnect between Washington and the
rest of the country it's it's it's
staggering how desperate people are
right now housing if you can even find
it is unaffordable mortgage rates have
soared people cannot afford to buy new
homes we are seven six and a half
million units shy to meet the demand in
the United States and we have about a
half a million human beings Americans
sleeping outside every single night not
just New York and San Francisco up here
in Manchester New Hampshire veterans
sleeping in the Parks it's atrocious and
we have to do a 7 million unit
initiative immediately to produce
housing in America Health Care 66% of
every of all bankruptcies in the United
States are from medical debt from
medical debt in the United States of
America we spend twice as much as any
developed nation in the world our
outcomes are mid-pack we allow and I
state that again we allow pharmaceutical
companies to sell their products in the
United States for three four five times
more than anywhere in the world when I'm
President we will find a way working
together to ensure that none of those
companies can sell their products here
for a penny more than they do in Canada
Mexico Great Britain France or Japan or
Australia period it's not that hard and
we're going to change the delivery model
from a fee for service to a capitation
model so we actually get away from what
we what is really a sick care system we
don't have health care it's a sick care
system so that's Healthcare and then we
have education $1.7 trillion do in
student debt uh at 5% interest that's
about 80 some billion dollars a year
that's burdening families and young
people who can barely get ahead and
we've need tuition free college we also
need to make sure that the debt that
exists right now I believe should be
interest free and we should absorb the
debt of any person who is willing to
develop their credentials or career in
something that serves the public so
these are common sense Solutions and
then groceries you know Andrew I you
know I come from the Vodka business when
I was in that business retailers were
not allowed legally charge us what they
call slotting fees those are the prices
you pay to rent the Shelf to put your
products on the Shelf but in the grocery
business when I was in the ice cream
business not only can they charge you
all the grocery chains around the the
country are charging rent to the bread
makers and the butter makers and the
cereal makers to put your products on
the Shelf so why do we have high grocery
prices of course it's obvious we have
too little competition and we have a
system not unlike the political
industrial complex the duopoly uh that
is literally making things more
expensive than necessary so if we don't
address these things and we don't raise
the foundation uh we are going to be in
big trouble and by the way uh I know you
are a big fan of Ubi I'm looking at a
bill right now that would do a pilot
around the country because I think AI is
going to almost require that we
completely change the lens of us
capitalism if we hope to remain a
democracy for many many years to come so
those things are on my mind border
security is on my mind chaos in our
cities is on my mind and probably most
importantly if we do not become a
country that ensures security for every
American and peace and prosperity in the
United States and overseas uh we are not
doing our jobs and I'm just afraid the
current generation of leaders from the
West Bank all the way to the West Wing
have got to be replaced with Next
Generation leaders who understand what's
coming who have a different worldview
different competencies and most of all
are ready to work together to solve
problems stop fighting each other and
start fighting for each other that's my
agenda it's not rocket science it's
entirely common
sense
this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's e p s vpn.com /y and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
yangang well I love how you're tackling
the main uh sources of misery in terms
of costs uh so that's housing health
care and education uh I'd imagine you
have some uh thoughts around vocational
and apprenticeship folks who who aren't
um heading to college I'm curious about
your ideas on what we originally
connected on which is campaign Finance
reform one of the things that I suggest
to folks Dean is is some people say to
me it's like oh uh Dean's a Democrat um
and I was a Democrat I left the party in
2021 because I didn't think that uh the
solutions were necessarily going to come
from within the party and what I try and
convey to folks is like no I mean sure
Dean's been a Democrat uh his his
political career um but Dean is actually
uh in many ways situated to be a
profound change agent if he wins this
thing and I joke and this is before the
machine has been Shing him every
day like he he wasn't a fan of the
machine even when it was like it was
like totally fine with him um so uh what
can we do to fix our broken terrible
campaign Finance system I'm so glad you
asked because you know that's why I I
did this work to resist Donald Trump and
to expose the truth about a system that
I really do believe is starting to work
against all of us not just the not just
the right but the left as well and I've
been a proud Democrat my whole life I
intend to continue to be I'm running as
a Democrat for a reason U but I think I
represent an extraordinary number of
Democrats around the country that are
growing very concerned about the
underpinnings of this entire party uh
and I believe that this is a time to
make a choice and to be courageous about
it and those choices have to start with
actually reformation and transparent
transparency of how this party operates
which in my estimation is shockingly uh
opaque dangerous and disenfranchising
but as it relates to reform Andrew um
first of all money in politics you know
I'm the only member of the entire House
and Senate 535 people that accepts no
pack money no lobbyist money no member
money and I don't have a leadership pack
I'm the only one out of 535 people which
means I find it hard to find friends and
colleagues to go to dinner with in
Washington on a Wednesday night because
they're all going to pack dinners
getting their white envelope with the
$5,000 in it going to another event I
hate that I'm also I don't do call time
I don't run across the street and dial
for dollars it's atrocious I actually
wrote A bill Andrew to prevent
fundraising in Washington between
breakfast and dinner because I see so
many people in Congress spending every
moment that they had free leaving
committee meetings leaving committee
meetings to go call people for money so
what's the problem with that when
Congress is spending 10 ,000 hours per
week raising money well here's the
problem who are they raising it from
only the wealthy and the well-connected
because you got to fish where the fish
are it's natural which means you're only
hearing from you're only congregating
with really wealthy people of course
they have expectations especially the
packs and the lobbyists that's their job
to influence you and we allow it the
bigger issue I think is this Andrew when
you're spending all that time with
people of great means by definition you
have no time to spend with people of
modest means which is the overwhelming
majority of this country 60% living
paycheck to paycheck 40% cannot afford a
$400 repair and 32% of the entire wealth
of the United States of America is held
by just
1% so when 535 members of Congress 534
because I don't do this are spending all
their time with really wealthy people
you're ignoring the people who really
need help so why do we think
trumpism happened because someone said
you know what I get it I'm going to give
them voice I'm going to pretend that I
care about them and I think it's time
for Democrats and independents and
thoughtful people in all parties to
start extending invitations but I'm a
Democrat I want to extend invitations to
disenfranchised angry people currently
supporting Donald Trump to join this
team the dean team because I get it I'm
angry too I want to drain that swamp of
the corruption of the low bar for ethics
I think we need term limits I think we
need open primaries I think we need rank
Choice voting I think we need to end
gerrymandering and I think it's time to
return to some form of publicly financed
campaigns so that every single candidate
from Joe Biden to Donald Trump to Dean
Phillips to Andrew Yang to Ronda santis
and Chris Christie and Nikki Haley don't
have to spend so much of their time
appealing for
resources I think it's anti-democratic
and I think it is completely undermining
the very foundations of democracy at the
very least I'll tell you I'm going to
expose the truth I'm going to continue
on this Mission and I think that is in
my in in my entire agenda both policy is
affordability peace and reform and I
call it relieve repair and
reimagine this podcast is sponsored by
Helix sleep it's a pretty short list of
things you can do that are going to make
you happier health healthier more
energetic more productive every single
day you know what's on that list getting
the right freaking mattress and what's
the right mattress for you if you go to
Helix sleep you take their personalized
sleep quiz and they will send you one of
20 unique mattresses made for you and
you alone well not you and you alone
like 5% of people do the math for 100
night free trial you can sleep on this
thing for 3 months it will keep you cool
don't just take my word for it my kids
seek out this mattress in the house it's
the number one rated mattress picked by
GQ and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yang this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now
I love it man that's a beautiful Vision
uh sign me up for term limits rank
Choice
voting open primaries and everything
else um I've got a personal question
let's say you do become president it's
2025 uh what would you want me to do in
the administration I've got a couple of
ideas uh one is Commerce where I could
rewrite the rules of the economy so that
they actually see how people are and
families are doing as opposed to just uh
GDP growth in uh the stock market so
that would give me a lot of Joy um the
other would be a department of
technology and Innovation where I could
both make good things happen but also
frankly regulate some of the um the new
developments out of AI that I fear
might end up uh being a double-edged
sword at best uh you know I mean I'm
deeply concerned about those things so
so there are people watching and
listening to this who obviously would uh
in enjoy um either of those things but
what do you think Dean like you here's
what I think Andrew I think I think well
first of all I will consider all of the
best and brightest in the country
including you and I'd be grateful uh for
your application and your participation
let me start with that what I think you
could also do is be the Ubi guy the Z
the Ubi Zar I've got this bill right in
front of me that I'm looking at right
now I think it is time that uh we listen
to what you are proposing so many of
your supporters believe so deeply in I
believe we should be a country that
should be experimenting as much as we
can right now uh to test ideas in the
same way that businesses and any
Enterprise any University any
organization will test something uh and
see how it works make some tweaks and
then roll it out nationally uh the
federal government has this bad habit of
coming up with big ideas that they could
never execute in a in a reasonable
Manner and I think what you just shared
with me are two great opportunities and
also I think Ubi is another and let you
know first first things first let's win
the race and then let's let ask
everybody by the way this is going to be
a very different Administration as you
know Andrew because it's not going to be
just a bunch of politicians who've been
doing this for 50 years this is going to
be I want to attract the very best
Americans not just Democrats the best
Americans with the best capacities to
ideate to innovate to manage to deliver
customer service to employ new
technologies you know we are not
attracting police departments our
military our federal government our US
Congress is no longer attracting the
very best and brightest because the best
and brightest are not attracted to it
and that's something we got to change
and you know Andrew I would love to talk
to you about ways that we can work
together and many others watching right
now and let's get there first because we
got a big task ahead oh no I know we've
got a work itut out for us but I would
love to be the Ubi guy I would love to
be the anti-poverty Zar talk about uh
something fulfilling I mean also I need
a common sense need a common sense Zar
too that's another role that I want to
fill yeah I mean after this all comes to
pass like it it'll it'll be fun en
listing uh the dream Dean Team the Yang
the Yang gang meets the dean team like
uh the the megaw coming together so so
one of the things that um people imagine
you know and I've I've uh been educating
people about the race I'll give you a
sense of my take on it but a lot of
people um when they they here here's
what I think has to happen sure uh so
number one is people become comfortable
imagining you as president and again I
think you would make a phenomenal
president you have the right uh values
character motivation uh you're just
going to try and solve problems and make
things better for as many Americans as
possible uh and you're doing it at a
spirit of service I mean your your
father and you mentioned military
veterans uh earlier um people might not
know that your father died in the
Vietnam War and and I know that Spirit
of service has been motivating you by
the way you look just like him I mean I
saw a picture of him holy crap I mean
you know like I showed Evelyn too and
she was like it just looks like a
picture of of Dean um so I'm me sure
that's you know you must be very proud
of your father so number one is people
have to get comfortable with imagining
you as president um and and that there
are a lot of things that go into that um
um um so that's you know like uh you
getting in front of people and becoming
more familiar with you and comfortable
with you hopefully conversations like
this help um and then the next is
putting up a big number um SL winning
New Hampshire and for people who don't
understand I think this is very very
winnable and achievable in large part
because uh New Hampshire has never loved
Joe Biden he's done poorly there every
time he's run and that was before he
demoted them in favor of South Carolina
in an act of what I thought was very
very self-serving honestly it's like uh
where South Carolina uh voted for Joe so
he said hey we're going to make South
Carolina First and and and even if you
thought that was an okay idea um what
became in my mind incredibly unfair was
that New Hampshire has a law on the book
saying it has to go first and Democrats
don't control the state legislature so
even if the New Hampshire Democrats had
said we want to do what you're saying
they literally could not
do what the what the the DNC um was uh
asking of them and so now new Hampshire
is voting on January 23rd first as
according to their law they they
should and as punishment the DNC has
said um one we might take away some or
all of your delegates and two our
candidate Joe Biden will not be on the
ballot so if you're a lwi information
Democratic primary voter or independent
in New Hampshire and you show up on
January 23rd uh Joe Biden's name will
not be there your name will be there um
there will be some other names there but
Joe Biden's name will not be there uh it
it also is true that 57% plus of
Democrats aren't comfortable with Joe uh
as the the nominee so if you put all
that stuff together if you can get the
energy uh and name recognition by
January 23rd I think you have a great
chance to win in New Hampshire that day
and then if you win there will be
approximately $500 million worth of Free
Press coming your way because the
incumbent sitting president would have
just la to the quote unquote No
Name you know only anything you want I
don't care yeah yeah the legislator um
and then uh millions of Americans will
tune in and they'll say oh my gosh uh
like we have an option I don't have to
just accept this crappy Biden Trump
rematch that I felt terrible about
that's it you just you just nailed it
Andrew it it I I think there's some
really interesting poetic justice that
is forthcoming in America only in
America can this happen where an
incumbent president along with his party
disenfranchises their very voters by the
way this is not disenfranchising
Republicans this is Democrats
disenfranchising Democrats it's it's
Preposterous in in the spirit of somehow
winning the next election so my message
to many Democrats here is wouldn't it be
remarkable wouldn't it be remarkable if
the strategy that they use to ensure a
coronation instead because of all of you
resulted in the very competition that
the country is begging for and that is
exactly what I think is going to happen
on January 23rd uh what has happened
Andrew not just here in New Hampshire
the State of Florida Democratic party
unilaterally decided that there does not
need to be an election that Joe Biden
won the election that didn't even happen
and all 250 delegates are going to be
going to him for the convention North
Carolina just two days ago same thing
decided unilaterally a handful of people
that they would only submit one name
which means there is no Democratic
Primary in North Carolina I I don't
understand how it is possible that the
Democratic party would literally
suppress millions of democratic voters
it is it's almost hard to conceive that
I'm saying what I'm saying is true but
it is and I think it's not just
hypocritical it's just downright
dangerous downright foolish and frankly
inexcusable and to your point a lot of
people aren't paying attention yet but I
think they will on January 24th the day
after we win New Hampshire and
demonstrate that the good news is that
the power is still in the hands of
people and I hope people come out and
demonstrate that because if they don't
not only are we going to have more of
the same we're going to have Donald
Trump as the next president and I will
not stand by quietly promise you
that happy holidays you know what's
tough to do during holiday season eat
right and not gain weight and not
frankly get a little extra tummy going
because you don't have time you're on
the go the way you can make it so you
stay healthy and charged up in the right
way is to use Factor America's number
one ready to eat meal delivery service
Chef prepared dietitian approved ready
to eat meals delivered straight to your
door this is the service that's going to
change your life I love their shredded
chicken taco bowl as just one example
it's not just for dinner and one thing
that's great about it is that it's
totally commitment free it's not one of
those things that's tricky you can turn
it on you can turn it off but you are
not going to want to turn it off because
it's going to change your life for the
better this December you can get factor
and enjoy eating well without the hassle
just choose your meals and enjoy fresh
flavor packed meals delivered straight
to your door ready in Just 2 minutes no
prep No Mess great for frankly the guys
who aren't going to be cooking for
themselves so well so head to factor
meals.com
sl50 and use code y50 to get 50% off
that's code y50 at factor meals.com y50
to get 50% off try Factor
[Music]
today oh well you're you're actually out
there uh trying to prevent it from
happening whereas other people are doing
things like circumventing the vote I
mean I I had a joke Dean where I said
look if the Democrats really don't want
anyone to vote uh in this primary then
just change your name from the
Democratic party to something more
accurate and then I I had I had some
suggestions that where bet you did um
you know that things like uh um the
leming party like the the follower party
you know I had some unproductive I know
you're a Democrat so you can't really
laugh come on be nice man just be
nice I'm frustrated Andrew you know I'm
frustrated because I have to make a
confession I was part of the problem I
was part of the problem I had no idea
for years I've been supporting
Democratic candidates for years
supporting the party I was a I am a
member of the party I've been a three-
term member of Congress I'm a super
delegate to the Democratic National
Convention based on my membership in the
US House of Representatives you know
this I've been a lifelong Democrat and I
cannot believe what I'm discovering and
I only would discover this having
entered my name as a candidate for
president and I'm afraid that's kind of
part of
the I gu that's part of the strategy I
might say that only if you do this can
you really discover what it really looks
like only if you do this can you really
open the hood only if you do this can
you look inside and see how the sausage
is made and they know it's really ugly
and it really stinks and that's why they
don't want many people to do it that's
why they make the hurdles so high to get
on ballots millions of dollars half of
my time right now is spent calling
states to make it through the impossibly
difficult circumstances they put in
front of you to Simply get on the ballot
in a Democratic Republic like the United
States they don't want us to see it they
don't want anybody to know about it and
if they can just keep it quiet and keep
people off the stage except for the ones
that are part of the coronation uh party
that they think they can hide it uhuh
I'm not going to let them hide it
anymore not going to let them hide it
anymore no matter what happens to me no
matter what this takes no matter the
endurance required uh to bring this to
light my goodness it'll be the biggest
gift I give to this country in my entire
life and as you said my father gave his
life to the country it's the very least
I could do is expose the truth about
what he gave his life for should matter
more than I'm seeing right now from the
Democratic party oh dude it is so
infuriating when when you see this uh
you know you have to uh essentially uh
back Biden for the sake of democracy and
then with the other hand they're like
and Le let's not have you vote uh you
know let let's uh make it so you have as
little Choice as possible I mean it's
very odd um that the approach and I will
share a story that you may not know um
so there are various folks who
approached me about running for
president in this cycle for the same
reasons where they said hey we think
Joe's going to lose and we we'd like
there to be better candidate um would
you consider and what I said to them I
said look I don't think the Dems are
going to have like a fair process um and
I don't think I'm the right candidate to
activate a fair process what's wild
about what's happening with you Dean is
like you're a super delegate you're a
three-term member of Congress you're
actually an Insider um uh and and but by
doing the principal thing all of a
sudden they're they're acting like who's
this guy it's like you kidding this guy
was like a senior member of your Club 10
seconds ago you know what I mean um and
and so there there are various folks
you know and one of the reasons why you
know you and I were discussing like gav
new the the JB prisk the gret Whitmer is
like I think that if you had a figure
like that then the DNC might actually
have no choice but to say okay like I
guess this really is like a like uh um
not a non-c coronation and then we're
actually going to put proper um uh
debates and other things uh in in place
you are a much much more of the- moment
figure to activate this process I think
you are fighting for the very future of
Western civilization in your race and I
think that uh the opportunity in front
of people to have real reform most
people don't see it in eug deene but I
see it clear as day if you become our
next president I think you have a very
real chance to become the transformative
leader that people have been waiting for
for Generations uh they just need to get
behind you and make sure you win this
thing on January 23rd in New Hampshire
so if someone wants to help you win in
New Hampshire and then compete in South
Carolina and then head to Michigan how
can they best do so well I'm first of
all thanks for the kind words Andrew and
and the feelings are mutual and if you
want to help and join the dean team de24
is my website and we're building it out
every single day if you can support our
effort financially with 510 15 20 bucks
my goodness it goes a long long ways and
I'll tell you the most important thing
even more than treasure is a little bit
of time and a little bit of courage and
that means activating advocating and
telling friends neighbors family
especially over the holidays coming up
it's a very as a marketing person
believe me I've created strategies in
the back in the past in my professional
life where we recognize the power of the
December holidays when people return
home and they're sitting at the table
they're watching TV they're having the
conversations that will be the most
important ones for the 2024 election so
anybody watching listening right now if
you might consider supporting us telling
your friends and family back home being
an advocate uh investing a little bit of
your hard-earned money in this
initiative because it is an investment
I'd be grateful and we're going to make
it fun we're going to make it
transformative we're going to bring joy
and hope and optimism back to a country
that really needs it and I will confess
I can't do it alone nobody does anything
alone anybody who tells you they do like
Donald Trump you know they can't but we
can do this together and I think this is
so this is so much more than a
presidential race it's not about me it
is about us it's about a system it's
about a country it's about a future if
you're a parent if you're a grandparent
my goodness the writing's on the wall
about what's happening next so please
de44ca you know I want to hear from you
uh you've shared so many with me Andrew
Ubi being one of them uh there's a lot
of great thinkers out there and the joy
of doing this is hearing from you and
meeting you where you are and uh Jan
jary 23rd is just going to be a
beginning because I'm going to keep
going and I'm going to speak for you I'm
going to listen to you I'm going to give
voice to the exhausted majority and
lastly do not let anger tainment have us
believe that we are more divided than we
really are so allow me to give some
space and place to Restoration of
America and to the repair literally
repair all of us and it's going to be
fun and it's going to be all of our
Legacy so join me in using a little bit
of your reservoirs of Courage because we
could all use it right now I love it I
have donated to your campaign Dean I
have made calls on your behalf and I'd
urge anyone else who wants a real choice
in 2024 to do the same thing you know
people in New Hampshire South Carolina
Michigan give them a call tell your
friends anyone who complains to you
about the Biden Trump matchup just say
oh you know who's going to improve on
that is Dean Phillips and if someone
says who then say look uh he's actually
America's best chance to beat Trump and
begin a new era in American politics
Dean Phillips the man who in my opinion
very well could be the next president of
United States Dean 24.com thanks
[Music]
everybody